[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'hebdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité
locale de cette semaine voici les titres
de ce vendredi 20 janvier un déplacement
ministériel ce matin du côté de
guyancourt laurence rossignol ministre
des familles et de l'enfant on s'est
rendu à la caf de saint quentin en
yvelines pour le lancement d'une
nouvelle agence de recouvrement des
impayés de pension alimentaire
joséphine coleman ce berger conseillère
départementale elle est notre invité fil
rouge pour cette émission parlera avec
elle de l'ambition de plusieurs
départements dont celui des yvelines à
développer l'axé seine dans le cadre du
grand paris pour atteindre leur objectif
les départements on crée notamment une
association enfin dans le reste de
l'actualité nous reviendrons sur le
déplacement des manuels cos la ministre
du logement dans les yvelines
retour aussi sur la cérémonie des voeux
de la ville de maurepas mon ouvre donc
cet hebdo a dû en cours avec le
déplacement ce matin de laurence
rossignol la ministre des familles et de
l'enfant s'est rendu dans les locaux de
la caisse d'allocations familiales pour
le lancement de la nouvelle agence de
recouvrement des impayés de pension
alimentaire ce nouveau dispositif doit
permettre de soutenir les familles
monoparentales et des les parents isolés
écoutez à ce propos la ministre au micro
de michael et demi d'euros on considère
que 30 à 40 % des pensions alimentaires
ne sont pas versées aux parents qui
devrait la toucher et bien entendu 85%
des familles monoparentales étant des
femmes
je considère que le non paiement des
pensions alimentaires est une violence
économique faite aux femmes
déjà la monoparentalité et 1p
précarisant tu mets le non versement de
la pension alimentaire rajoute de la
précarité et des difficultés financières
c'était leur dernière cartouche les sept
candidats à la primaire de la gauche ont
débattu pour la dernière fois ce jeudi
soir avant le premier tour qui se
tiendra à lui dimanche un débat
articulée notamment autour de la
sécurité sociale de la justice ou encore
du revenu unis
cl une proposition phare de benoît hamon
le député de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines
lui qui sera forcément attentif à son
score dans son fief électoral
écoutez le au micro de nicolas landry
mais je le regarde avec attention
j'espère que je serai en tête dans la
11e
j'espère oui je suis s'est passé pas du
tout acquis d'avancé 1 mais évidemment
je regarderai ça avec intérêt
je vais voir g6 si le monsieur fourgous
fait voter contre moi et elle encore
s'amuser bien comme de la donner un euro
parti socialiste je pense que ce sera
trop pour lui bon moi je suis pour
l'instant candidats à l'élection
présidentielle viendra le temps de deux
législatives et si si je ne suis pas élu
prétend la république et mais le coup on
en parlera à ce moment là mais juge
toutes les indications soient évidemment
bonne à prendre mais tout ça n'est pas
beaucoup de surprises avec jean-michel
choses non ce sera ouhlala benoît un mot
c'est horrible ils déposent de l'argent
benoît hamon c'est le passé bon et
dimanche pour le premier tour de cette
primaire de la gauche benoît hamon se
reposer à six autres candidats que vous
voyez à l'écran vincent peillon
sylvia pinel arnaud montebourg manuel
valls jean luc bennahmias et françois de
rugy et pour savoir où voter dimanche
entre 9h et 19h vous pouvez consulter le
site www.lesprimairescitoyennes.fr
joséphine coleman ce berger vous êtes
notre invité fil rouge pour cette
émission conseillère départementale vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et maire de plaisir je voulais vous
faire réagir sur ces actualités
politiques les plus récentes est-ce que
vous la primaire de la gauche c'est
quelque chose que qui vous intéressent
même si ce n'est pas votre camp
politique
est-ce que vous suivez tout de même les
débats à titre personnel
bien sûr bien sûr c'est important je
veux dire oui c'est pas ma famille
politique mais c'est important nous
sommes dans une année de je pense de
transition en tout cas et de grandes
démocraties dont il est important en
temps qui lui d'être au courant de ce
qui se passe et de voir bien sûr ce que
les candidats nous propose le candidat
de votre camp c'est françois fillon quel
sera votre rôle pour cette
présidentielle est ce que vous vous
voulez vous engager à titre personnel
dans un cadre local ou peut-être plus
important quel sera votre rôle vous
restaurer je resterai à ma place c'est à
dire la place que vous avez évoqué avec
mais mes différences engagement
politique mais il est clair que je serai
derrière françois fillon puisque c'était
le principe bien sûr des primaires c'est
à dire et bien de suivre ce qui va se
passer dans les semaines qui viennent je
serai présent et je serai bien sûr
auprès des personnes qui se battront
pour ça sur le territoire évidemment
l'actualité politique est également
américaine puisque seuil et donald trump
est investie officiellement président
américain c'est une énigme pour beaucoup
de personnes pour beaucoup de politiques
du monde antique va-t-il réellement
faire est-ce que vous
vous êtes inquiète titre personnel
comment vous regarder ça de plaisir j'ai
envie de dire les yvelines des yvelines
aussi de france même carrément je pense
avec le gir inquiétudes inquiétudes
curiosité mais laissons le temps au
temps
mais savez il ya la période de la
campagne et il ya la période où on
investit aujourd'hui l'air en retour à
la réalité
j'ai l'impression de toute façon je
pense qu'il va être fortement conseillé
autour de lui et que il ya des enjeux
aujourd'hui nationaux au niveau des
états unis et internationaux qui vont un
peu l'obliger à changer un peu de cap
d'ail or il l'a déjà fait lors de son
dernier discours où on sentait déjà
qu'il y avait une rondeur et une rondeur
qui ne peux je dirais que nous plaire
quelque part mais laissons le temps au
temps
on va voir on passe à présent à un sujet
beaucoup plus local mais non moins
intéressant le développement de l'axé n
5 départements dont celui des yvelines
se sont donc associés il ya plusieurs
mois pour favoriser son développement
touristique économique culturel et ils
ont créé l'association des départements
de l'axé seine c'était en juillet
dernier vous étiez alors en pleine
journée d'hier découverte des
problématiques des sujets avec quelques
pistes de réflexion déjà six mois plus
tard où en sommes-nous est-ce qu'il ya
déjà des propos des projets concrets qui
ont tous deux jouaient ce que vous en
savez un peu plus sur ce que vous voulez
faire ensemble
écoutez déjà il y avait une prise de
conscience qui était nécessaire
cette prise de conscience est venue du
grand paris dans la réflexion globale et
bien sûr il ya une évidence qui est
apparue celle de l'axé seine comme étant
comme vous le dites et un grand temps un
grand enjeu important
les départements qui vont du val d'oise
jusqu'aux scènes les yvelines l'eure et
maintenant jusqu'au calvados avec la
seine maritime
eh bien on s'est réunis vous l'avez dit
justement et je concrétise on s'est
réunis pour travailler ensemble pour
voir comment nous allons développer il y
a déjà des projets les projets sont
importants puisqu'ils sont sur plusieurs
dans plusieurs domaines il ya des
domaines de développement économique
avec bien sûr toute une série de
développements autour et le long de la
seine mais aussi touristique et aussi
deux manifestations
aujourd'hui on a des
vrais enjeux qui sont des enjeux d'
approche auprès des entreprises auprès
des collectivités des intercommunalités
de la région des régions puisqu'on
touche aussi la normandie pour pouvoir
créer toute une synergie avec une vraie
volonté l axe seine qui traverse tous
ces territoires jusqu'à présent c'était
sous exploité je vais vous dire la scène
elle était là elle est là depuis
toujours mais tout ce qui s'est
construit autour à part l'industrie les
villes tourner le dos à la scène c'est
assez paradoxal assez antinomique
et on vient de se rendre compte
j'exagère et je caricature un peu que la
scène est un vrai potentiel dans tous
les domaines et aujourd'hui on tend à se
tourner vers elle et voir qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec ce fleuve
extraordinaire qui mènent quand même de
paris la mer on a un homme le
développement économique par exemple
qu'est ce que vous pourriez développer
autour de la scène sur surtout ces
territoires qu'elle ce qu'elle peut être
les projets qui peuvent voir le jour
alors si par exemple nous parlons du
tourisme puisque vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui le tourisme est un vrai
souci puisque on dit que nous sommes
nous en perdition touristique avec ce
qui se passe bien sûr au niveau de paris
dans les îles et dont on n'a pas eu de
baisse
extraordinaire mais on s'est rendu
compte que justement il y avait du
potentiel des installations qui sont
nécessaires aujourd'hui le long de la
seine comme des hôtels comme des
restaurants comme aussi des ports de
plaisance qui sont aujourd'hui attendu
comme aussi toutes les balades le long
de la seine avec l'avé 33 que nous
souhaitons développer qui est une piste
touristique cyclable parce qu'on n'a pas
l'impression mais ce tourisme là est
très puissant et les personnes qui
viennent à vélo faire le long de la
seine s'installe mange et pourquoi pas
aussi consomme
il y a aussi eu un développement très
important depuis quatre ans est bien de
tout ce tourisme avec les bâtons
aujourd'hui il y à 18 bateaux qui font
le long de la seine qui suivent la scène
a été multiplié par quatre en quelques
années et on se rend compte qu'il faut
installer des ports des ports non
seulement de plaisance comme je vous
disais mais des ports aussi qu'ils sont
des ports commerciaux et des ports
touristique et puis il ya l'industrie
l'industrie est présente bien sûr vous
le savez sur le bord de la scène
mais il ya encore beaucoup de choses à
faire et puis on travaille également
avec les ports industriels comme un
repas qui sont du havre jusqu'à paris et
qui aujourd'hui sont en train de
regarder comment on peut sur développer
toute cette activité économique vie à la
scène et non pas via la route
l'objectif aussi des départements à ce
que c'est aussi de favoriser le dialogue
entre tous les acteurs de la vie autour
de la scène c'est à dire les territoires
mais les industries vous en parliez les
habitants la vie locale
toute cette vie là tout à fait on s'est
rendu compte que les départements c'est
pas des ans dont il était frontières
c'est comme la scène ça coule les
départements on passe de l'un à l'autre
le fait d'avoir créé cette association
de ces départements nous permet de nous
réunir régulièrement sous l'égide des
présidents justement des départements
pour pouvoir ensemble créé toute cette
synergie trouvait bien sur tous les axes
que nous développons devons développer
et ça nous donne une force importante
vis-à-vis de l'état des
intercommunalités de la sncf de tout ce
qui est portuaire enfin c'est à dire
tous les acteurs qui vont être en face
de nous c'est pas pour être dans un
contre au contraire c'est pour être dans
une co-construction et le fait d'être
1,5 avec la même dynamique et bien va
certainement donner des résultats
beaucoup plus rapides que ceux ci en
était simple c'est simple de travailler
à 5 ou alors chacun a ses ambitions ses
points de vue ses envies non je trouve
que c'est assez simple parce que
aujourd'hui les ambitions sont très
similaires
très similaire même si les territoires
sont un peu différent parce que si vous
comparez les hauts-de-seine acquise sur
les yvelines et le calvados
c'est pas la bonne chose mais on a les
mêmes besoins on a bien besoin
véritablement de développement l'emploi
c'est aussi quelque chose qui est au
coeur de notre réflexion et c'est
valable tout au long de la seine dont on
a forcément des intérêts communs et des
envies communes donc cinq acteurs
majeurs mais je vais dire pas six on se
demande où et paris dans cette affaire
puisque quand on pensera à la scène on
pense évidemment et c'est logique à
paris et paris ne fait pas partie pour
le moment du projet pourquoi quand je
vous disais grande valeur politique
le groupe le grand paris a quand même
remarqué qu'il y avait l'axé seine
aujourd'hui effectivement on peut dire
que c'est le projet s'arrête
non c'est caricatural bien sûr qu'on a
des contacts aussi avec paris l'enjeu
est pas tout à fait même vous avez pu
pour été accélérés ces contacts aller
plus loin oui c'est impératif mais vous
allez constater qu'aujourd'hui paris se
concentre beaucoup plus sur l'intra
muros
alors que nous on essaye est bien de
faire un lien justement d'ouverture et
de développement on souhaite
véritablement et on sera les acteurs de
ce rapprochement est paré pour une
intelligence de territoire qui va bien
du coeur de paris jusqu'à la mer pour
terminer sur ce sujet un coup d'oeil
peut-être sur l'agenda 2010 est avec une
première importante qui verra le jour en
juin d'un festival de la scène qui va se
dérouler sur trois jours sur 500 km
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous en
parler écoutez pour le moment on n'a pas
vraiment la description c'est pas parce
que je veux faire la langue de bois
c'est parce que c'est en cours de
construction on a été très vite sur
spéciale au mois de juin il y aura une
manifestation importante qui va relier
tous les départements pour en avoir
parlé aujourd'hui les choses sont pas
tout à fait déterminé je vous promets
que dès qu'on aura plus d'informations
je vous les donnerais c'est à dire que
nous avons eu la création en juillet
vous aviez regardé nous sommes seulement
au web de janvier bien sûr tout le monde
travaille tout le monde se mette en
place si on essaie de voir comment on
peut coordonner les choses et
aujourd'hui je suis pas très à même et
je vous le dis en toute transparence de
vous donner plus d'informations que cela
mais je sais qu'il y aura beaucoup de
manifestations le long de la seine
joséphine coleman ce berger rester avec
nous on va continuer à parler de sujets
locaux avec l'actualité de la semaine
et cette semaine a été marquée par un
autre déplacement ministériel dans les
yvelines les tailles l'association
habitat et humanisme se sont associés
pour lutter contre le mal-logement un
phénomène qui toucherait près de 3,8
millions de français d'accord a été
signé en début de semaine à jouy en
josas par la ministre du logement
emmanuelle cosse dans la nouvelle maison
intergénérationnelle construite dans la
commune un reportage de michael et demi
d'euros la ministre du logement
emmanuelle cosse était à jouy en josas
ce mardi 17 janvier la représentante du
gouvernement signé à cette occasion une
convention d'engagement d'utilité
sociale avec habitat et humanisme une
association qui lutte depuis 30 ans
contre le mal logement et l'insertion
des personnes en difficulté la corse
établi sur la période 2017 2020 c'est un
engagement que le président de la
république m'a demandé de renouveler
notamment en mai dernier en me demandant
de réouvrir dans les cinq ans 7500
places de pension de famille qui sont
vos loyers des structures qui sont à
cheval entre eux on va dire un centre
d'hébergement et un logement pérenne
avant cette signature la ministre a
également visité les locaux de cette
maison intergénérationnelle implantée
avenue jean jaurès cette dernière
comprend 48 logements sur deux bâtiments
au total 80 personnes devraient
s'installer dans la structure d'ici fin
février la volonté de la dette du projet
et c'est d'avoir un une mixité il y à
des familles ont des familles normales
landa si on peut dire
il y à des seniors isolés
il y à des personnes isolées
il ya des moments des familles
monoparentales et des étudiants et des
jeunes travailleurs la maison
intergénérationnelle ouvrira
officiellement ses portes le samedi 21
janvier avec cette inauguration
l'association habitat et humanisme
dépassera les deux mille familles logées
depuis sa création elle et veut continue
sur l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines il ya quelques jours c'était
tout on ne mord pas de souhaiter la
bonne année à ses habitants et
différents services grégory gary astier
le maire l ère de la villa a dressé un
bilan de l'année écoulée notamment
autour de la réhabilitation de plusieurs
établissements scolaires comme celui de
la marnière et des friches des travaux
qui continueront sur l'année 2010 est il
a aussi annoncé le projet d'un centre
aqualudique les précisions au micro de
mélanie poker depuis maintenant un an
nous travaillons et que mes deux amis
collègues maires de coignières et
d'elancourt sur un nouveau projet parce
qu' il vaut mieux détruire et
reconstruire en lieu et place du site
actuel plutôt que de bricoler dans une
structure qui de toute façon était en
fin de vie et ça coûte et même plus cher
donc on repart sur un nouveau projet on
est en train de justement de terminer le
montage financier que l'agglomération de
saint quentin on a toutes espérances
également que les intérêts
communautaires soit voté pour que le
chantier soit lancé joséphine coleman
berger vous êtes première vice
présidente de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge du projet
de territoire c'est donc un sujet qui
vous concerne l la piscine et plus
globalement la définition des
compétences de l'agglomération ce qu'on
appelle les intérêts communautaires des
compétences qui ne sont toujours pas
défini un an après l'entrée on va dire
en vigueur de l'agglomération élargi à
12 communes cela veut-il dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines tourne au ralenti
non il faut pas dire ça je pense que
justement beaucoup de choses ont été
faites depuis janvier les les
compétences obligatoires sont mises en
place et on a déjà bien avancé
bien sûr on travaille aussi sur les
voiries a déjà des mutualisations qui se
font avec les différentes collectivités
et je peux vous dire que les choses
avancent bien
aujourd'hui les intérêts communautaires
dont parle mon collègue grigori gary
sied à l'intérieur desquels bien sûr
rentrer cette discussion sur les
piscines
pas tout à fait mature on va dire même
si j'entends tout à fait à mon collègue
qui a véritablement cet enjeu de cette
piscine qui concerne trois collectivités
on a pu on a pu constater en tout cas
après une étude que sur l'ensemble de
notre territoire
il manque véritablement de piscine c'est
une vérité aujourd'hui c'est la forme je
dirais qu'ils manquent dans la décision
globale des douze villes de savoir de
quelle façon nous allons accompagner ou
intégrés dans les intérêts
communautaires par exemple les piscines
mais il n'y a pas que ça dans le sujet
des intérêts communautaires si on n'est
pas au ralenti et est que la majorité
souhaite que cette piscine soit
communautaire
non je pense que il faut que la majorité
comprenne je dirais l'intérêt global du
territoire
cette piscine dont fait partie comme
d'autres certaines villes ont choisi de
ne pas intégrer dans l'intérêt commun
des intérêts communautaires leur piscine
parce que ça fonctionne bien pour le
moment elles n'ont pas besoin d'être
fait
on doit avoir une réflexion globale vous
me rappeler à juste titre ma
responsabilité sur le projet de
territoire je crois que l'enjeu est là
aussi
aujourd'hui et nous avons pas de retard
sur le projet territoire on a commencé à
travailler dessus il nous faut il aller
31 décembre d'ailleurs 2017 pour établir
les intérêts communautaires par exemple
oui mais les intérêts communautaires
bien sûr le projet de territoire il sera
fait juste avant je pense qu'il y aura
cette concomitance bien sûr entre les
deux quand le projet territoire sera en
place ne sera plus à même de penser de
voir quels sont les axes véritable que
nous souhaitons prendre et il y aura des
logiques et des évidences mais je
comprends bien qu'aujourd'hui monsieur
grégory arrestier connexes s'inquiète
pour ne pas pouvoir démarrer ses travaux
c'est une véritable attente depuis qu'il
est dans sa ville
il a été obligé de fermer la piscine
pour toutes les raisons que nous
connaissons tous et c'est un véritable
problème
derrière ces sujets il ya aussi des
tensions politiques entre la gauche et
la droite vous qui fait partie des
nouvelles communes entre dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines est ce que vous été étonné de
voir de telles tensions qu avec quel
regard vous portez dessus ce que vous
vous fait pas forcément partie de la
génèse de ces tensions
est ce que peut-être ça vous pousse à
jouer un rôle de médiateur entre gauche
et droite jeu l'ancien agglomération
essai j'essaie j'essaie d'abord pas
parce que je suis dans une ville en 30
je connais saint quentin en yvelines
depuis la genèse je n'étais pas dedans
mais j'étais dans les parages et j'ai
bien vu cette naissance
il me semble et je n'achète pas de
langue de bois parce que depuis le
départ j'ai toujours défendu le fait que
nous devions travailler à 12
et c'est quelque chose que je revendique
haut et fort donc quand vous parlez de
tension je vais dire incompréhension
peut-être je vais dire décision à deux
vitesses qui va plus vite qu'il va moins
vite je n'en sais rien je ne porte pas
de jugement je dis simplement et c'est
ça que je voulais dans le projet
territoire c'est apprendre à travailler
ensemble et travailler ensemble
nous ne créerons pas une agglomération
ambitieuse et de grande qualité si nous
ne travaillons pas à 12
est-ce que vous ambitionnez ne partent
pas quatre personnes vous sembler très
optimiste ou l'agglomération j'allais
dire pourquoi c'est parce que maintenant
que je connais les maires je connaissais
un peu mais beaucoup mieux je m'aperçois
que tout le monde est dans une volonté
d'intérêt général est que parfois il
faut savoir oublier un petit peu je
dirais nos polémiques deux parties même
si je suis dans mes valeurs de droite
parlons de votre villa vous plaisir dont
vous êtes la mer quels sont les projets
qui vont marquer l'année 2007 l'agenda
2010 est de la ville de plaisir
il ya la rd30 déjà c'est un vieux projet
dont on a traité cette semaine également
sur l'avancée du projet il ya d'autres
d'autres choses qui m'ont guidé cette
année vous avez raison la finalité de la
rd30 déjà c'est une chose oui on a
d'autres projets et travaux d'open sky
ont démarré donc là aussi sont des
choses très important on a aussi un très
gros projet qui sort de ne pas de terre
mais je dirais en tout cas du concept
c'est tout l'étude sur notre centre
bourg qui nous permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir une vision parfaite de ce que
nous allons faire de ces vingt hectares
qui sont au sein de notre collectivité
qui sont encore un potentiel fort pour
nos promoteurs et je souhaitais mettre
en place ce projet là de réflexion pour
ne pas faire n'importe quoi il laisser
faire n'importe quoi je veux avoir la
maîtrise du foncier et de ce que plaisir
ce sera dans quinze à vingt ans et on
aura beaucoup d'une opération puisque on
avance bien et très vite merci josé qui
comme le berger d'être venu en plateau
et pour vos réponses dans le reste de
l'actualité locale cette semaine il y
avait du bien être avec elle et massages
qui connaissent de plus en plus un
succès fulgurant c'est une tendance
entre tensions au travail fatigue
musculaire ou encore le froid persistant
en ile de france et pour rester au chaud
nous sommes partis à la rencontre
d'ariel à savoyen qui dirige l'atelier
de massage cinquième sens à versailles
reportage de mathieu demy et camille
lambert ambiance tamisée et chaude
éclairée à la bougie musique douce
ariel savoyen apaise les mots de ses
patients cette voyageuse transmet son
savoir à travers le massage est donc à
chaque fois je me faisais ma c thaïlande
vietnam pendant vraiment dans beaucoup
d'endroits et à chaque fois en effet je
me faisait masser
parce que j'aime vraiment ça et je me
rappelle toujours d'une fois c'est en
thaïlande où je me suis fait masser et
ça remonte à je dirais 20 ans à peu près
et quand la personne hamas et je me suis
dit je rêverais de faire ce qu'elle fait
j'ai créé l'atelier de massage en 2011
en février 2011 donc ça va bientôt faire
six ans on est à versailles celle à
versailles un échange un geste un
mouvement et une énergie
c'est ce que communique ariel savoyen
durant ces séances avec ses mains elle
décèle chez intentions cachées plus plus
on masse plus on se rend compte des
tensions des personnes de son choix est
le sport qu'elles peuvent pratiquer on
peut s'en rendre compte aussi par la
musculature et puis et puis surtout vous
avez à chaque fois différents et ça
c'est super amateurs ou d'un client
régulier ariel savoyen s'adapte aux
patients et propose différents types de
massages alors vous allez massage
californien qui est le massage plus
enveloppants et le plus facile à
recevoir je dirais qu'ils s'adaptent
vraiment au gré des besoins de la
personne
après vous avez le massage ayurvédique
qui est un massage d'origine indienne
qui régule les énergies qui s'appuie sur
la médecine lier vedaquais la médecine
indienne via le massage balinais wannsee
x massage un cinquième sens qu'elle a
développée et qui a porté ses fruits
arial savoyen est en train d'ouvrir un
nouveau salon un pari à découvrir en
février prochain
cette semaine nous vous avons aussi
présenté le combat d'un engin ange nommé
nathan ce petit garçon de neuf ans est
atteint d'une maladie neurologique
orphelines et pour l'aider à aller mieux
ses parents lui font suivre notamment
des traitements à l'étranger des
déplacements et des voyages qui coûte
malheureusement très cher une soirée
donc organisé ce week-end au cabaret du
bout des prix de cerner la ville
objectif récolter des fonds pour aider
nathan hale et ouais
sylvère le way se levait tenir droit
debout sur ses jambes voilà des gestes
des efforts devenu possible pour nathan
après des mois et des années
d'apprentissage
né en novembre 2007 nathan est un bébé
alors comme tous les autres il pleure
jouer passe du temps dans les bras de
ses parents
les choses se compliquent en octobre
2008 nathan devient alors sujets à des
vomissements des tremblements anormaux
qui a commencé à être dans les vapes
on la change les comportements il
bougeait plus trop et guy fixer des
choses on sait pas quoi mais fixer des
choses il a commencé à vomir
donc on avait pensé à une gastro enfin
voilà les périodes où on si c'est pas
grave quoi c'est surtout quand il a
commencé à se mettre à trembler que là
on va trouver ça bizarre
s'ensuit alors un long combat pour
nathan et sa famille combat contre des
médecins qui ne mesurent pas l'ampleur
de la maladie mais aussi pour trouver un
traitement efficace
la situation de nathan ne s'améliore
réellement qu'en 2010 avec la mise en
place d'un nouveau programme anti
épileptiques
un élan de solidarité la création une
association permettent eux de financer
des thérapies à l'étranger en espagne
nathan réapprend à tenir debout à se
concentrer sa vie s'améliore problème
les stages coûte cher plusieurs milliers
d'euros pour trois semaines en 2016 on a
réussi à faire de ce stage en espagne
deux semaines et trois semaines sachant
que trois semaines de stage c'est 5000
euros donc on a fait également un stage
d'une semaine au centre brain move à
saint malo pour en attester
on a financé des orthèses on a financé
une poussette enfin là il n'y a pas que
la thérapie en soit il ya aussi tous les
à côtés tout ce qui est médicale pour
l'aider au maximum la soirée inattendue
organisé le samedi 21 janvier à cerner
la ville permettra de financer une
partie des stages prévus cette année
elle permettra également de continuer le
combat de nathan c'est la fin de ce set
8 l'hebdo merci de nous avoir suivi une
reportage on a retrouvé en replay dès à
présent sur notre site internet et tv
fil 78 points com ou sur l'application
mobile la tv fil 78 bon week-end à tous
et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e